what's happening you bad [__]
it's Monday May the 8th the joint is
brought to you by on it listen it's time
we're having the Semi-Annual Sale till
May 14th at honest kettlebells gut
health they got it all so do me a favor
go to island.com right now look at all
the great things they have the
supplements kettlebells Club bats I mean
at Macy's they got it all I'm gonna save
you some money with this sale so go to
the semi-annual sale right now at
audit.com if you see something you like
you want to save some extra money throw
in Diaz Joey or church in there and see
what it gets you hope they'll get you
ten percent but listen this sale is
gonna be great so if you're looking for
some new supplements if you're looking
to try
here's your chance on it.com slash Joey
the joint is also brought to you by
manscape you bad [__] summer is
coming up and your body will soon be
glistening in the sunlight make sure
you're grooming that nut sack on point
with manscape that dedicated to upping
your confidence by giving you all the
tools they need let me tell you some of
that performance package is on fire the
new lawnmower 4.0 will knock you into a
fight you nutsack and the pogo stick
will look its best it's looked in years
the performance packet 2.0 was a
lifesaver it includes the essential
lawnmower 4.0 waterproof cordless body
head trimmer and you ready for this the
weed whacker to get all those [__]
disgusting hairs out of your nose and
some extra goodies for the crown jewels
while you're at it deal with the
toenails like mine which she is 2.0 male
kid that work on my toes so don't worry
about it get 20 off in free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com again
that's 20 off and free shipping with
code Joey at manscape.com trim your
testicles with your vesticles
[__] and now it's time to get
this party started
thank you
hey how you doing come on
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
greetings you bad [__] it's
Monday the 8th of May holy [__] what a
[__] week guys it's a beautiful day
to be alive Monday the 8th ready to
tackle some [__] here first off I want
to thank everybody who purchased the
book the audible the Audio I don't give
a [__] it uh
listen man I I Eric and I wrote a book
we did the best we could
did I think anything that I think I was
Mario Puzo or [__] uh no not at all I
just wanted to tell my story it was one
of my goals and
I gotta tell you I am more overwhelmed
than ever so thank you
for all the [__] support and people
putting up the pictures and me
retweeting your pictures with your
[__] teeth out and [__] it was it was
it just was really great it's a real
great feeling
I can't tell you guys that
you know
I've been walking on like a dream all
week like this was I can't tell you like
Monday was kind of weird Monday night
and sleep which I I just could not fall
asleep
and then Tuesday I woke up the phone
calls and congratulations and [__]
uh since Tuesday I've been feeling like
up I'm [__] naked
like I'm walking around naked like I bet
everything to you [__] over the
years on the podcast yeah we
spoke about different things and [__]
but you know when you tell a story about
robbing somebody you can look at it
objectively but when you
read the backstory
still a piece of [__] thing that I did
but when you read the back story you go
wow
okay now I could be a little bit more
lenient on them I didn't know what was
going on in his life at that time yeah
you don't you don't know you just don't
know so when you tell these things in
isolated ways
you know you string them together and
you explain that's what I wanted to do I
always there was two things I always
wanted to do
tell my story number one and number two
explain myself
explain myself not that I needed to
explain myself to [__] anybody
I want to explain myself for me that was
it that that just to let you know
what happened I told you all the bad
points in my life I told you all the
good points in my life
and I'm very proud I stand behind both
of them I don't listen things [__]
happened okay
but the most important thing is that
we're still here you know and I learned
I just learned a lot from writing this
[__] book I thought I had it figured
out and you really don't man
it makes you look at your life and
everybody else's Life's a little bit
more objectively like you look at it
like it made me get out of my body
and look to see what the [__] was going
on so this has been an education
so I appreciate you guys letting me do
this
even though it took 18 [__] years and
that's what I tell you guys man
listen man whether you're quitting drugs
whether you want to cut I don't
everybody tells you you need to get a
college degree in four years that's what
they tell you I know some people have
gotten in three two and a half but I've
also known some people that took six
didn't take six years for birth Chrysler
to [__] graduate yeah I mean yeah
listen guys it's it's a struggle it's
your journey it's your [__] Journey
you know we always rush ourselves to oh
my God I I Gotta Be A Millionaire and by
the time I'm 25 hey bro you got 10 cents
in the bank and you're 19. how are you
gonna [__] be a millionaire unless
you hit the lottery unless you bet the
Celtic I don't [__] know I don't know
so
you know I'm not better than you guys
I'm not smarter than you guys I wasn't
born with a Golden Spoon in my [__]
mouth you know everything I got I had to
[__] work for it it's funny there's a
dear friend of ours in the neighborhood
I mean dear friend
the kids like my kids you know they have
a little boy who was born with a [__]
football a baseball and a basketball in
his hand
it's just a tremendous little natural
athlete he's got a sister
and she started playing softball
a little after Mercy started and
she struggled the first year she didn't
know the rules you know
and the second year she went back and
she had some of the things guys this is
what I watch I love when people get it I
love when the switch goes off okay
and she struggled whatever the coaches
recommended that she go to a batting
instructor
she struggled again without the batting
instructor but this time a little bit
more
and now I went to watch it this morning
I went to watch this Saturday morning
and I got to tell you some guys she
scored twice
she struck out three [__] people you
know and I and she was so [__] happy
she was so happy and it meant the world
to me but it meant the world to me I
pulled her aside and I go remember when
we had a talk that he would just get
better
was I lying to you
I go and how much better does it taste
that you had to work for it
you know guys some people don't have to
work for it but then it all falls apart
the people that work for it they [__]
fight to keep that [__] like I did you
gotta fight regardless of what the
consequences are you got to keep [__]
fighting every day and pushing
and uh you know I I'm gonna see her
later I'm gonna see her like this week
oh my daughter's got a game with a and I
sent the text to the mom I go I wish you
were at the game and Mom had to work on
Saturday I wish you were at the game
see the Improvement it took three years
it took three years for her to become a
player
she's not Willie Mays yet but do you
know what I'm saying like it takes
[__] time you can keep banging your
head off the [__] wall
a thousand times so take your time enjoy
it enjoy the ride don't worry about
Peter's doing don't worry about what
Jake is doing
cause you know what it's all about you
[__] always keep that in mind
and that's your [__] little Monday
kicking the [__] ass I was blessed
this last week to uh be able to do are
you garbage
if you guys notice I've been getting out
more I need it I needed to go into the
city more and uh
do some [__] podcasts last week we
had to cancel bar stool till this week
so I'll be doing bar stool this week I'm
doing Andrew Schultz in a few weeks so
things are starting to move a little bit
more
I have not heard anything on the book
signing so don't ask you know as soon as
I find out I'll be just as happy as you
[__] so
don't ask and uh we'll [__] leave it
there but the all your garbage guys
I'll tell you what really
I think Wednesday night I was watching
something on TV with the family
and I was thinking about the office the
old podcast office you know
and they came over me how much I missed
that place like I I
that was just not an office that was a
place on Earth
for a little while that I don't know I
don't know when I think about that
office sometimes I go what the [__] was
that in there there was never you know
everybody assumed whatever was going on
in there guys you saw what the [__] was
going on there two fat [__] getting
high until they couldn't talk anymore
you know that's all the basic of what it
was guys could we pull it off again now
today not in a million [__] years but
it was for that the excitement I get
when I walk into that office sometimes
I'd throw my bag sit down smoke a few
[__] bong hits [__] with Lee you
know and when you had like a guest that
you really [__] knew it made such a
great difference it really was
I missed the office so much that I
actually called late that night
it's like midnight and I go can I ask
you a question do you miss the [__]
office
he's like it's funny you said that I was
titled man that office just had
you gotta see guys when we ripped up
carpet up I wish you guys could have
seen that I really wish you guys would
have seen
how beautifully disgusting it was when
we ripped the carpet up especially in
the area where we used to sit because we
picked it up and rolled it out so
everything could roll down
guys there was [__]
there was more THC dust buds
[__] acid that had disintegrated like
in the [__] the liquid acid that just
[__] ate through the bottle
like eventually that thing ain't through
the [__] bot I mean it was just when
you picked that [__] up and it rolled
down and you saw it you were like
I don't know what I should be happy or
[__] sad or I should call an NA
meeting to come here and bless the room
oh I should bust out the [__]
Exorcist [__] the power of Christ
compels you
it was really a [__] different
situation when I walked into are you
garbage I felt that same energy it was
it's a certain energy
it's a certain energy you tap into
when podcasters are hot like when their
podcast is beaming and there's a certain
energy you fall into and it was just
great to see I hope the podcast went
well
I hope you guys are [__] happy with
it you know what it is what it is I'm
gonna get out there and do some more
podcasts the next week and uh as you see
today we're doing Audio Only
you know we want to try something
[__] new here uh we're a little burnt
out with the YouTube thing I'm sick of
looking at me you're sick of looking at
me you know
so we're gonna do different things here
listen I always appreciate it when I
started the podcast I didn't know
anything about YouTube
we didn't do anything with YouTube I
really appreciated podcasting for one
[__] reason I tell you what the truth
is I appreciate it that it made us
listen again
I always looked at those pictures from
the 50s and the 40s when you see a
family sitting around a radio
listening to The Green Hornet or War of
the Worlds with whatever or whatever
[__] you know show they were watching
Sergeant Bilko there was all these radio
pictures when I was a kid and I would
watch that and go wow that seems so cool
it seems kind of [__] but at the same
time it seems kind of cool like when you
look at it that you that you just
listened
no visual you just sat there with one
ear towards the thing you know when I
was growing up and you got earphones you
got an AM radio you didn't get speakers
with it you got a chord with just one
plug and you had to sit there with that
one [__] I still remember being in
the fourth grade with one of those
radios that had the waves and you get
China and [__] like that at like 18
levels that's the only [__] thing I
ever wanted a raffle in the fourth grade
I run a [__] radio like a CB and
everything what's those things here hey
trucker one nine uh CB radio everything
in there I could talk to truck drivers
at night and get molested when in the
fourth grade it was [__] crazy
and I would listen to I would wait all
night to listen to
to see if Elton John's
Benny and the Jets would come up this is
how old I am guys all right I was dead
when Benny got real that was the hot
song like 73 72 I was maybe eight nine
maybe seven nine a little older than
seven and I would sit there all night
under the [__] covers with this radio
one with a plug
connected to one [__] thing I used to
remember walking around this city I
streamed being a kid and walking around
New York City when you had a
ABC WABC ran a contest and it was about
[__] if they caught you with a
sticker on you won twenty five thousand
dollars let me tell you something I had
15 of those buttons on me at all times
when I was seven and eight years old I
would walk back and forth on Times
Square back and forth by [__]
Broadway and eighth I'd be walking all
over I never bumped into one of those
[__] ABC people but to bump into him
you had to listen to the radio and
they'd tell you there's a guy standing
by 34th and seven get down there now
when you got the there's no ABC guy but
I still remember that it was just the
cord connected to your [__] ear
so when podcasting was introduced like
you know when Rogan all those guys were
doing it Marc Maron I really I used to
listen to Mark a lot in the beginning
because it was audio
you know I don't know when he
Incorporated the video part of it but I
think a couple months he just had audio
everybody was just audio for a few
months
and it was [__] tremendous like I
liked listen the reason why I like these
[__] for years I did [__] album of
the week and all that stupid [__]
because I want to bring all that [__]
back
there was something to sitting down
opening an album and reading the insides
of it
and just rolling a joint on the inside
and sitting in your room and there was
just something to me I always felt that
was special and I think over the years
that got taken away from us
people
just don't [__] listen and that goes
for me too
you know I mean listening is the biggest
gift that we have
and we live our lives not [__]
listening not really focusing on little
things and Little Words
so it was like okay I really enjoyed the
podcasting again because I thought we
would bring it back that whole world you
know everything was pointed at that [__]
coming back look at the success of
albums the last few years I think three
years ago yeah three years ago vinyl
sales so I thought people would get back
to listening again and I got back to
listening heavy during the pandemic I
mean we all did we all had to listen to
[__] and music and all this [__]
but
you know now I've been doing this
podcast on tape for what 10 [__]
years now I think Felicia and I did no
video yeah we didn't have video we
didn't have video
I think I'm a lot more Freer
I think I don't have people's eyeballs
looking at me and [__] like that so I
just wanted to try it this way for a few
weeks just to see what the [__] happens
to spice up things and uh you know who
the [__] knows
so just work with me I don't know if
it's gonna work for you but I want to go
Audio Only now that said I do enough
[__] my face is in a lot of [__]
places now for me to keep doing this
stupidity I want to go something
different the best thing about going
into the city though Friday
you know guys we take so many [__]
things for granted in our lives that's
why I tell people when you're not in the
right headspace come home
come home come home
take a ride to the same take a ride to
where you went to school park the car
walk to school
and walk back to your car or better yet
park the car
go to school from your house and walk
back the house
just try it one time
see how empowering you [__] feel like
you just feel empowered you know
when I was in a bad situation 1993 I
came home and for the first two months
my situation here wasn't much better
but I forced myself to walk from
Cliffside to North Bergen every day to
work at hashways I did that for a reason
because it would make me walk past 85th
Street and all these places that I knew
I would sometimes this is 30 years ago
and I could walk I didn't have knee
problems I would dip down into North
Bergen where the rocket ship was and
just see the old neighbor but I wouldn't
even have to see anybody it was 10 30 in
the morning people were at work or
whatever the [__] they were doing it
wasn't about seeing people it was about
walking those streets and seeing where
you got
your momentum from you know so yesterday
whenever I take the ferry I usually hook
a right on River Road and [__] go up
the Roadies that's that's my that's my
quicker fixing up I go to Rudy's I get
the Rhode Island nice the Rhode Island
[__] clam China it's the red and the
white put together
and then I uh get like a salad or
something or a half water fried Calamar
with the [__] crispy shrimp well done
and I ride home it's about a 55 minute
home ride home but yesterday
I put the [__] thing on in the car to
see how long it would take me to Rudy's
it was like a half hour it was already 2
30.
that means by the time I got to Rudy's
it would be three o'clock and then by
the time I order and get out of there
four I would get I wouldn't get down
here until 5 15 5 20 and I had the uh
the Florentine crime family through a
little bash for myself and Erica just
like a little dinner at the restaurant
in Neptune so I wanted to make that I
thought about going to [__] Rudy's
gig last night my apologies I know a lot
of you guys went to see Quiet Riot up
there in njpac and Edge Englewood
I was stuck down here till [__] nine
o'clock but the moral the story is on
the way back I was like [__] it because
when you get off the ferry on the Jersey
side you're [__] you know maybe a
half a mile from Route three 495 which
turns into three which rolls into the
turnpike so I was like you know what I
think I'm gonna go that route but I'm
still [__] hungry
I'm [__] hungry you know
I hadn't eaten anything since [__]
eight in the morning I had the knee
doctor for the PRP to check out the knee
and the progress and then I was gonna
and then I shot to the [__] City so I
didn't really eat anything
the city was [__] beautiful you know
and I saw all those sad bread hot dog
stands and I'm like man
we were talking about all you got we
were talking about the sad bread hot
dogs are you garbage and they're like
they don't even have them in the city
they buy those umbrellas they're fakes
like I thought so because the last time
I got a a [__] uh hot dog in the city
wasn't that good well anyway
if you pull into the 495 and if you wait
to go into the 495 guys you will sit
there for two [__] years it is one
night I tried to do it I I was there for
like seven [__] lights and what
happens is the people don't stop at the
light so the cars can't go through
yeah but people keep walking the people
keep not in the not the people keep
walking the people keep driving they run
the light and then they because they
want to catch that light so now you're
stuck there it is brutal so last week I
said [__] this I'm not doing this again
and I took the outside Lane which takes
you right into Union City all right now
if you've ever been to this part of the
country
when you get off the Lincoln Tunnel
where The Sopranos woke up this morning
when it goes around you're in Jersey
when you turn
you got two [__] options you can
either go into Hoboken or you're going
to Weehawken all right or you go to
Union City those are the first [__]
things you see when you land in Jersey
if you go up the hill and you look at
Union City
it looks like an old rustic tunnel I
mean the post office is still there from
before when I was a kid
and they have like these viad ducks
where people from Route 3 come into the
city so you're driving over them
basically they're on D when I was a kid
I would go to those things and throw
pennies off there at the [__] please
forgive me because my mother's bar was
right down oh my God every day me and my
buddies nunzio a bunch of us would throw
pennies at the car we [__] run like
little idiots that we work
so the other day I was like I'm pluck
and starving and I could really go for a
hot dog but I don't think that hot dog
guy is there anymore
dog my mother closed that bar in 1978.
and her ball was on 29th and Bergenline
and I'm 30th and Bergenline around the
corner
was a [__] hot dog man that had been
there for a long time
he took numbers as a matter of fact he
was like an illegal bookie there I think
he was Spanish I don't [__] know you
know I don't remember
then years later they moved them to New
York Avenue and 30th Street which is
right down the corner headed towards the
city and there's a U-turn you can hit
that Landry right there and I'm at that
light and I look and I saw the hot dog
man was there now he's been there
at that [__] spot since I got to be
maybe 20.
and he sells steak on a stick he's not
an Arab guy he's a Spanish guy he sells
steak on a stick [__] thick pieces of
beef and he puts Frank's hot sauce on
that [__] with two pieces of
Italian bread
and he has the best hot dogs sad brat
all the way bug I'm tempted of getting
back in the [__] car today ain't
going up there later on that's how good
the [__] steak on the stick was
and the story with all my points and
Weight Watcher [__] I inhaled two
[__] onion two [__] uh
what do you call those red onions this
Sab red sweet spicy onions with mustard
oh my God I had two of those
[__] and while I was waiting he
just kept handing me those those [__]
uh sticks with bread on them I ate three
of those [__] sticks
Snapple iced tea and then I made a
YouTube a schnapple iced tea like a
[__] and then I made a [__]
U-turn I got back on headed toward the
three and I saw that you know what's the
Spanish [__] town like Union City is
like 80 Spanish now you know
and I made a u-turn I had it down I see
I saw some women selling fruit and [__]
I pulled up I bought some pears some
[__] mangoes but I got one of those
coconuts with the straw in it that you
drink the fresh coconut juice stop it
stop it I was in [__] heaven
I was oh yeah I had the Snapple the
[__] the coconut water for
dehydrational purposes
and then the beauty of it was
I'm standing there in front of this hot
dog guy
and all of a sudden I remembered
I'm looking at this bar across the
street I'm like holy [__] I used to
bartender
it was a a guy from Union City's name
was Teddy martuniak he played for the
Chicago Bulls in the 70s big [__]
drunk dude
six foot six and sweet out of a guy
but this guy was a [__] walking drunk
I had never seen anything like that I
think he got thrown out of the NBA
because he was just an Irish [__]
dude you know from Union City
and this guy he bought a bar
for his own personal playground like
when you buy a bar for you and your
friends
you know you're a [__] alkie okay you
know you're a [__] alkie and I got
nothing against that I got my own
[__] promise you know what I'm saying
so I got nothing against that if it was
up to me I would have put a Colombian
cocaine place when I was 22 but uh you
know who had the money for something
like that so
I'm looking at this place now it's like
Maria and Sons you know it's definitely
everything in that part of town now is
Spanish I got nothing against I'm just
trying to make a how much the town
change I didn't even look at the bar
while I was eating those hot dogs I
didn't look into the bar because I was
across the street maybe 15 feet what not
far at all
and while I'm sitting there I'm thinking
about how I walked in now
when I was a senior in high school and
talked that dude
and to let me bartend
I quit school already I got fired from
nasdaq's training or Sentry Hardware and
I had [__] I was collecting I sued
them my union there was a wrongful
firing and then they kept me laid off
until they picked up again so I'm
collecting big money
you know I'm collecting like 450 a week
when you're 18 in 1982
get the [__] out of my faith 1981 and
I'm under the table working at this bar
and he's like you know do you know how
to make drinks and I'm like come on what
nobody in here is only drinking martini
you know it's going to be a long island
iced tea a whiskey shot
or beer the bar had like a little pool
table TVs in the daytime some Cuban
bookies hang out in there that were left
off from my mother's boss when I knew
those so when I when I went in there for
applying for the job guys 18.
not even out of high school yet and when
I applied for the job all those guys
women like yeah hire them he [__]
grew up in his mother's bar he knows
what the [__] he's doing don't worry
about okay
[__] hired me and this guy's like I
only got two ships
he goes I got Monday nights
and I got Thursday mornings at 7am to
three
and I'm like can I ask you a question
who comes in here at 7am
and he goes all I got to tell you is one
thing if I give you that 7 A.M shift
you better be at 6 30.
he goes I'm telling you he didn't tell
me why
he never told me why he just goes I'm
just telling you what do you think I did
the first day I was late as a
[__] I thought there'd be nobody
that
Mike when I pulled up
there was 30 people there
because down the corner is that post
office I spoke about
and there's a bus station that's the
last bus to New York City that's the
last place you'd catch a bus in Jersey
now remember every bus passes through
there if you get picked up in South
Jersey and you're going to Lincoln
Tunnel you pass through that so there's
a bus every two seconds you can see him
stacked up like people going to
different buses
these [__] would be in there at
seven o'clock and all of them would take
uh two shots with a beer back
7 A.M Mike on our way to work on the way
to work and their hands would be shaking
while I gave him the drink their hands
would be dogged that was an education
guys that's an education when you see a
[__] coming fresh from breakfast
throw a cigarette on the sidewalk come
in get a shot of whiskey with a beer
back and then do another [__] shot of
whiskey and run to the bus with a
cigarette in your mouth that's [__]
seven in the morning that was 30 people
there waiting on those
and out of the 30 24 of them would be
shaken
it was insane it was insane and then I
would nothing after eight o'clock
I'd make a quick 60 bucks
but nothing after eight o'clock
nothing I would just sit there getting
hot dogs my hot dog man across the
street and [__] all day until my buddies
would come down my buddies would come
down sometime in the afternoon before
they went into the city to get their
[__] menu items for the evening this
episode is brought to you by better help
stop taking care of others all the time
take care of yourself for a change
better help let you take time that's
just for you talk through life for the
licensed therapist all from the comfort
of your home with your feet up relaxing
better help is entirely online no
sterile doctor's office no commute you
do therapy when and where it works for
you listen I'm not with uh better help
anymore I was withdained for about nine
months and uh it changed me if you
listen to the earlier podcast I was lost
at least I'm still lost but not as lost
so take some time for yourself and just
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
matched with your therapist listen if
you don't like your therapist they
easily switch your therapist at any time
for no additional charge I'm gonna save
you a bunch of money with better help
and get you better if you could tell
mental health is killing us right now I
was one of those people but I found
relief with betterhelp.com
um so do me a favor go to betterhelp.com
Diaz Diaz get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
Diaz now back to the show all right
we're back now so Monday nights he gave
me
and I'm like what am I gonna do with
that on Monday night it wasn't even
Monday night football anymore I took the
job like maybe
I'm not sure
maybe I didn't have the job Monday Night
Football
talk the first Monday I was there I
invited all my buddies every one of
those drunks
so I told them all listen you got to pay
for a beer but for everybody you pay for
it I'll give you a beer and give you a
shot
so if you paid me for eight beers you
got 16 beers and [__] eight shots
you're getting [__] up all right so
I had about 100 [__] down there
maybe 80 [__] down there the
first night he called me Tuesday he's
like that's the biggest cash register
I've ever had in a Monday night I broke
like a thousand bucks on a Monday night
with high school kids with [__] high
school kids with [__] high school
kids I broke like twelve hundred dollars
in the register from four to [__]
three in the morning
so the next Monday he was dead all my
friends came up and they had like
somebody to respond to the [__] night
like Bud Light not even no no not the
[__] beer I don't even want to say
that here I'm [__] uh they got
somebody to [__] sponsor him we did
like three of them that way and then
he's like those Monday nights are too
wild for me your friends are a little
too wild guys we weren't [__] high
school
and then one Monday one of my dear
friends Darren Rago God Rest his soul
got into a tremendous fist fight with
another friend of mine named Larry the
Hat
Larry the Hat I love that [__] name I
knew Larry that I knew both of these
[__] since I was you know a kid
and here they are my bar fighting each
other I mean it was a [__] tremendous
fight they ended the fight in the
[__] van somebody had a van they oh
my God every every Monday was something
but the beauty about this bar was and
this is when it gets interesting guys
[__] uh there was uh there was a girl
that worked there with me and I grew up
with it
her name was Darlene she came from a big
Italian family
me and her were always dying to my
friends growing up we [__] at the
basketball court now we're older she was
a couple years older than me
and she started working that but let me
tell you how the system worked there at
the end of the night you see it out you
counted everything
and you left the bank for the morning in
the register you know whatever it was 50
bucks 60 bucks
and then you took the rest you put an
envelope and you put in the refrigerator
like he had a regular refrigerator in
the back with beers and like hot dogs
and whatever [__] he would make them
and you would put it up in the top thing
and I'm like [__] that's crazy I leave a
thousand dollars in that envelope
overnight
I gotta get to that somehow or another
so he gave me a key so what I figured
out was the nights that I didn't work at
that time you didn't have the high-tech
alarms like you have now to tell you
what time somebody came in or to notify
you it was just an alarm with a key you
know
so let's say I was in the city at a club
with my friends and we're driving back
on Wednesday at four in the morning I go
stop in the club and I go in the back
I'd walk in get like a soda the place
would be closed I'd hear the mice
scattering
and open up the refrigerator I take an
envelope
rip it open take all the bill out and
then put in a new envelope
with the same amount
so the old envelope said 880 878
I would take that money out 878 dollars
take a hundred out
put the receipt in there with everything
and put 878 778 let's say that's it I
did this for about three weeks it was
driving them crazy
they couldn't figure out I mean and I
never thought about that girl getting in
trouble but for some reason I was always
taking the the hundred when she worked
the ship
so she could not figure it out and one
day she kind of figured it out and she
called me and she's like are you going
in there at night and taking the money
I'm like no
why would I drive 80 [__] blocks you
know what's what's the matter with you
no and she's like there's something
weird the teddy guy called me a few
times what the [__] is going on down
there
I'm like I don't know I don't it's not
me you got like 20 bartenders you know
he had two ships a day yeah it's seven
days a week that's 14 different parts I
only had two ships
chick had like three some guy with a
there was a chick that had a glass eye
with big tits that worked there yeah I
mean it was just a [__] it was just a
[__] you know
so this went on for a few weeks and this
girl had a boyfriend who I grew up with
and at the time this guy was a scary
dude he was [__] uh
working with some dudes that were not
doing good things and he called me one
day and said can we meet for coffee now
I grew up with this dude I grew up going
to his house I knew his family I mean I
knew his dad I knew his mom
and when we met he was laughing about it
he's like you know that's great that
you're getting a little Vig out of there
blah blah blah
but my girlfriend's getting in trouble
and I go we'll have her start stealing
I go what the [__] is wrong with you
what am I the only one there stealing
all these bars are filtered Fifi [__]
bartenders you know they can't barely
make the wreck because these bartenders
are stealing with three hands
well that's not the school she came from
I said listen man
whatever you know we left on a good no I
mean this guy was my brother we used to
come down here when we were kids
together we come to Englishtown through
the [__] mall to the English town
yard whatever the [__] the swap meet and
we buy hot sneakers and listen to BTO
[__] uh taking care of business we
were kids and he was a little older than
me he drove you know but he drove when
he was 16. he didn't give a [__] this
guy that's how bad he was of the
[__] so this you know he called
me again like a month later he's like
hey man
it's over you can't keep stealing
and I'm like Brother come on
you got in fact his younger brother got
me a job when my mother died at a lumber
yard and told me ran out listen do me a
favor if I quit you got to keep stealing
because I can't let them know that I was
robbing because if I didn't steal then
they'll go what the [__] is going on we
would you know all this [__] was missing
so he goes you got to keep this is from
a family that told me to keep stealing
now the older brothers are here to stop
still I'm like dog I'm not doing it
I'm sorry I'm not [__] doing it he's
like do it again we're gonna have a
problem so what did I do a week later I
[__] did it again because he was my
brother like he ain't gonna [__] hurt
me we're gonna talk about this [__] but
the last time he came to me he was gonna
hurt me that's how crazy he was at the
time you know
I don't know if I stopped stealing I
don't know how it ended I think they
changed the door locks well I don't
[__] know I just know I never got a
call back one day but it was so weird to
walk in there when you're such a young
kid like
I can't a [__] high school Mike when
I was sitting there and I'm sitting
there you ever see like a flag like a
movie it has like a flashback scene like
that's what I have like how who the [__]
would hire me at 18 years old
I think it was 18. when I first started
drinking in Jersey was 18 because
I remember my friends would steal their
brother's licenses and then sell the
replacement license didn't have paper
they didn't have your picture on them so
it was a lot easier to [__] drink
back then then there's nothing I guess I
don't [__] know
but just the whole thought of that me
standing there for 20 minutes eating hot
dogs going
and I remember one time like I was just
looking at the thing and also some guy
beat them he goes Joey's back in Union
City because that was my whole you know
Union City like I I know one of the guys
up there that's a commissioner with dear
friends he's the guy that got me my
first Johnson and Johnson covet shot
I mean with really tight and I've been
to Union City at night it looks great
like it looks beautiful but
you got to see this this place has so
much history that nobody talks about
it's an old Irish Town first then the
Cubans started coming in because of
embroidery
and like the late 40s and the 50s and
they all lived together there's a bus
station there it was so blue-collar if
you watch the Irishman that's where the
guy's bar was
from the Irishman that uh
that made whatever disappear you know it
was it had
so much Rich history Fidel Castro got
arrested there
in Union City that's where he started
his Revolution Union City New Jersey
Tampa Florida and [__] you know Miami
I mean it's such a [__] historic town
I could tell you that like I went to a
Christmas party a few years ago
and some kids say he was from Union City
at the party him and I got into a
40-minute conversation
about what Union City used to be it was
like a [__] Haven man of
of fun
just a [__] Bergenline Avenue
if you don't know anything about
bergenland Avenue you better ask
somebody [__] it runs from 7th
Street all the way up to [__] 88th
Street To None guesses
and I mean
Union City has Bergenline up to 48th
Street then it becomes West New York and
West New York becomes North Bergen
but that burger line I got so much
history on Bergenline like I would love
to park the car and just walk down like
the best Cuban sandwich in the country
is 52nd and Palisade Avenue everybody
knows that that's hands down as organic
old school and old-fashioned in fact he
makes Cuban sandwiches two ways
pre-revolution with pepperoni for the
Italians and [__] without pepperoni
for the non-italians that's when you
know a guy knows this [__] Cuban
history that's the time of [__] you'll
see the problem is now I'm so out of
touch with that because I'm not up on
those streets no more walking the [__]
around but I'll tell you one thing when
I was standing there even the [__]
steak on the stick I've had steak on a
stick from in New York City from you
know nice little Muhammad guys to
they're just nice guys
and the stake on a stick it's kind of
weird this [__] steak on the stick
mic it was like eating your mom's
[__] beef stew that's those steak
chunks those beef chunks oh my God and
he soaks them in barbecue and Frank's
Hot Sauce whatever you want there was
Brothers coming up there that was
everybody was stopping getting two three
four [__] one of those sticks I'm
like
I gotta stop back up there again but
[__] Union City just has so I got it
when I started reading like the the TJ
English book about
battle
I I didn't know that they had car bombs
in Union City but I remember being a kid
and there was a Russian guy that taught
Judo in Union City on 7th Street you
know there's a [__] kung fu school
in Union City that's been there for over
40 years
it used to be on top of the Carvel
bottom of the [__] barrel for anybody
who knows bottom of the barrel is in
Goodfellas the book The Wise Guy they
used to hang out at bottom of the Barrel
in Union City I'm telling you this is a
[__] historic little town that nobody
talks about and while I was sitting at
the other damn I'm looking at the old
buildings on the corner of 29th and
30th and uh whatever that [__] street
is Bergenline
you can still see in the bricks there
was a florist there
from the time I was a kid he was the
nicest guy in the world his name was
chappie
and that was the name of his florist
shop Chappy's floral shop
I could name that whole block when I was
a kid 29th Street from the time from my
mother's bar on the corner
to speak up in his Bakery which is one
of the best bakeries I [__] ever ate
at next to that was a sneaker store and
we were kids they used to sell Coach
Conns which were the cheaper Converse
the 7.99 Congress for 9.99 if your mom
got your coach cons oh you got beat the
[__] up coach cons and then and then
next to it was [__] Champy's flowers
so
it was just great to go up there and
just stand out there
and just look and I remember across the
street from there from
across the street from my [__] that
bar I worked at right there crossing the
hot dog man this whole cab place
when Atlantic City opened
that place was a Depot for people want
to go to Atlantic City like the [__]
mooches
so it's ten dollars to go to Atlantic
City but when you get that Atlantic City
they give you ten dollars in quarters to
gamble with and they also gave you books
with deals you know
go to the library get a free book you
know because after you lose you gotta
the problem with those buses were when
you got on the bus at eight and if you
went to Atlantic City you got there at
if you lose by 11 you got to sit there
till five that's in the contract that's
in the redefined print you can't get on
a one o'clock bus
so they give you these coupon books to
go like a free comedy show I never
performed at one of those comedy shows
but I have tons of friends that tell you
it's just people killing time that lost
money they look like they're going to
kill themselves they're over there
writing like a [__] they're doing
like a diagram of a noose and [__] just
in case
that was there but the most famous story
from that [__] place was there was a
cat place there
still there I think not no no I don't
think it's there I looked over
it used to have because the office I
mean that side of the street was really
sunny
and they had those shields on the glass
that you could see out but you couldn't
see it a lot of times you would just
walk in there and go I need a cab and
they go wait outside he's gonna pull up
in three minutes and you go outside and
pick you up
you know I
I'm talking to my butt the cab company
it was wild there was issues in that and
I guess New Year's
we're at uh Tom and Corky's this bar in
North Bergen and we're [__]
you know was just starting to get a
groove on we're doing a couple bumps I
think there was a couple [__]
Quaaludes in the air
and all of a sudden uh
we're in North Bergen and a friend of
all is a dear friend of ours who I still
talk to
walks in and he goes hey man you guys
gotta help me out my dad got hammered
and he went to take a cab and he got
beat up at the cab place and we're like
what now we're already [__] up you
know it's 11 30 at night 11 o'clock at
night
and my my one body who's nuts he goes
let's go down there you know let's see
what the [__] is going on worst case
scenario we're going to the city and get
some Coke or whatever you know because
it's right there close to the city
so we get down there we follow the other
guy in the car and he's got like a guy
with him and then there's four guys in
my car it's not my car I'm in the back
seat I'm a brokster and we all get out
of the car my friend goes
you know he's like listen this has to do
with me
it has to I have to go in there and
avenge my father they had my father your
guys follow this
so give me the bat I'm gonna go in there
first if something happens
if something happens I'll come out and
get you guys you know
so we're like that's perfect because
we're [__] up man you know the
Quaaludes get kicking in
Coke and now we gotta go arm wrestle
with these guys I'm I'm not a tough guy
I don't even know what the [__] going
on every time I drink and throw a punch
I get beat up I don't want to get beat
up again down here
so we get down there and my friend gets
out of the coming he's like let me go in
there and avenge my father's death now
we're sitting outside and you could see
not my father's death my father getting
hit
you could see what goes on inside like
very
you know I'm saying like there's a light
and if you walk in I could tell a
silhouette of you it's a silhouette of
you right so
I [__] I'm standing up with my
buddies were probably drinking and being
like let's let him walk in
we see him walk in and slam the door and
take the bat and hit his hand
and then was it commotion and you
actually saw somebody take the bat and
hit him on the head with the bat his own
[__] bat
now we're sitting outside we're like
what the [__]
what do we do we don't have a bat the
[__] guys took the only bat we had
and all of a sudden that dude walks out
holding on to his head he got hit in the
head with a with a bat now we're all
[__] up you know my friends got his
deck out he's pissing you know we're on
[__] a block from Bergenline Avenue
and the guy comes out into my friend
shocked my friend looks at him and he
goes who hit you Mickey Mantle I mean
because the guy was bleeding everywhere
and then I don't know what happened I
don't remember if we went in there I
don't think we did we just put a bandage
on his head and took him to the hospital
or something that was yeah the [__]
night that's why I hate [__] New
Year's Eve now you get it and I think
the year later when my other buddy got
his ear bit off so
New Year's wasn't fair to us anyway
that's my story
about [__] Union City today and
that's my uh that's the Monday
motivation podcast [__] we did
it it's gonna be a great week
and that's it
I don't know what else to tell you
[__] I'm happy thank you for
supporting the book Thank you for always
supporting me what's that
thank you brother and thank you for
accepting this new uh audio podcast and
see where this goes have a great week
stay black
and now for a worth my [__]
sponsors all right I want to thank you
guys for having my back on these solo
podcasts I'm trying everything I can but
the joint is brought to you by Anna
today listen I've been with on it for 12
years
just tremendous from the from the
everything they got the club bats the
[__]
listen I'm out of words for how great
their service is so do me a favor go to
on it with the supplements to
kettlebells you're gonna be [__] in
shock this is your time the Semi-Annual
Sale it runs till May 14th the joint is
also brought to you by manscape listen
summer's coming up your body will be out
there in the open for people to see make
sure you don't go out there looking like
the [__] Wolf Man
manscapers dedicate themselves to
helping your confidence so you can go
out there and sling dick like the
[__] Savage that you are I love
manscape the 4.0 has saved me money at
times I use it for everything he is bald
[__] I don't give a [__] and now they
got the performance packet 2.0 which is
Tip Top mcgloo Magoo it includes the
essential lawnmower 4.0 waterproof
cordless body hair trimmer and the weed
whacker 2.0 perfume for grooming those
nose hairs and the ear heads and while
you're at it deal with the toenails too
which she is 2.0 nail kit get 20 off in
free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com again I'm Gonna Get You 20
off and free shipping with code Joey
j-o-e-y at manscape.com trim your
[__] nut sack the summer's coming and
you want people to lick those nuts so I
want to thank better help I want to
thank manscape and I want to thank Anna
but most importantly I want to thank you
[__] remember the power of
Christ compels you stay black have a
great week and I'll see you dirty
bastards next week
[Music]